لقد طلب منا Facebook مشاركة بياناتنا
لمشاركة حياتنا على هذه
المنصة وأراد منا أن نتحلى بالشفافية
ولا يشعر الناس أنهم تلقوا
نفس القدر من الشفافية ، فهم
يتساءلون عما يحدث لبياناتهم
هل يمكنهم الوثوق  Facebook نعم ، لذا فإن
أحد أهم الأشياء التي أعتقد
أننا بحاجة إلى القيام بها هنا هو التأكد من
إخبار كل شخص تأثرت بياناته
بأحد هذه التطبيقات المارقة بشكل صحيح
وسنفعل ذلك سنبني أداة
حيث  يمكن لأي شخص أن يذهب ويرى ما إذا
كانت بياناته جزءًا من هذا لأنه عندما تم
الكشف عن ذلك ، علمت يا
رفاق أن هذه البيانات
كانت موجودة هناك لماذا لم تخبر المستخدمين
ألا تعتقد أن المستخدمين لديهم الحق
لمعرفة أن بياناتهم تُستخدم
لأغراض مختلفة ، لذا نعم ، دعني
أخبرك ما هي الإجراءات التي اتخذناها
في عام 2015 ، أخبرنا بعض الصحفيين من The
Guardian
أنهم رأوا أو
كان لديهم بعض الأدلة على أن
مطور التطبيق هذا  الكسندر كوجان من  قام d
ببناء تطبيق اختبار الشخصية هذا
واستخدمه مجموعة من الأشخاص وشاركوا البيانات
معه وقاموا ببيع تلك البيانات إلى Cambridge
analytic وعدد قليل من الشركات الأخرى وعندما
سمعنا ذلك ، كان هذا مخالفًا
للسياسات التي لا يمكنني فيها مشاركة البيانات
بطريقة لا
يعرفها الناس أو لا يوافقون عليها ، قمنا على الفور
بحظر تطبيق Cogan ، وعلاوة على
ذلك قمنا بعمله بحيث يقوم Cogan و Cambridge
التحليلي والأشخاص الآخرين
الذين شارك معهم البيانات التي طلبناها
شهادة رسمية بأنه ليس لديهم
أي بيانات من أي شخص في مجتمع Facebook
أنهم حذفوها إذا كانت
بحوزتهم وأنهم لم يستخدموها
وقد قدموا جميعًا هذه
الشهادة بقدر ما فهمنا
في ذلك الوقت تقريبًا  الحلقة لم
يكن هناك أي بيانات هناك متابعة تعلم
أنك تقول إنك معتمد لها أعتقد لماذا
لم يكن هناك المزيد من المتابعة لماذا
لم يكن هناك تدقيق ، فلماذا
يستغرق الأمر تقريرًا إعلاميًا كبيرًا للحصول على هذا
النهج الاستباقي  حسنا انا لا اعرف
عنك ب  لقد كان برنامج ut III مستمتعًا أيضًا عندما
يشهد الأشخاص قانونًا
أنهم سيفعلون شيئًا يفعلونه ولكني
أعتقد أن هذا كان خطأً واضحًا عند
الرجوع إلى الماضي